THE BATTLE KEEPS HEATING UP! Because the One Piece
Manga just revealed that ANOTHER INSANELY powerful
force is about to join the fight! In fact,
right at the end of the chapter we see some
mysterious force destroy a marine battleship that
was sent to destroy the civilians who escaped from
Egghead Island. And to make sense of what we are
seeing here, let’s first go back to chapter 1089,
where we first learn that the ship with
all the Egghead citizens evacuated THE DAY
BEFORE. Which is a super important detail
we will discuss more in just a moment,
but in that chapter we see that once the marines
had located this ship, Saint Saturn ordered their
IMMEDIATE execution because he didn’t want
the Egghead secrets to escape the island.
Now, if we jump back to the current chapter,
we know that SOMEONE destroyed that marine
vessel that was sent to wipe out
the evacuating citizens. And the
reason this is so exciting is that if
someone is here taking out Marine ships
then that means that an entirely new group of
characters could soon be joining the MASSIVE
CHAOS going on at Egghead Island. But this
might not actually be who you would expect.
Because the most straight forward assumption
that I think Oda wants you to make is that
this is the work of the Blackbeard pirates
since we have been waiting for them to do
SOMETHING ever since we saw their ship arrive
at Egghead way back in chapter 1079. But this
ABSOLUTELY cannot be THOSE Blackbeard
pirates since we know the civilian ship
left the day before the current events,
so they should be pretty far away at this
point while those Blackbeard pirates were
on Egghead right before the battle started.
So we simply must ask, if not those
Blackbeard pirates, then who could this be?
Well, the first option I’m going to throw
out, even though I don’t believe it,
would be the Straw Hat Grand Fleet. I mean
we’ve also been waiting for these guys to
do something for the longest time, but
we’ve seen Luffy in way worse situations
before and they’ve never shown up. So I’m not
counting on these guys showing up at this time.
The next option is that this could be A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT group of Blackbeard pirates. Because
remember that we know Blackbeard was somewhat
near Egghead since he clashed with Law soon
after the Surgeon of Death left Wano, so it
is entirely possible that even if Blackbeard
isn’t already at Egghead, he could be close
by on another ship. And if this is true then
of course we just have to ask why he would
take out the marines, and the best answer
is not so he can save the citizens but so that
he could take them hostage and use them to get
something that he wants from Dr. Vegapunk.
Now, whether that is some sort of weapon,
or maybe some cloned devil fruits or something,
we can’t know. Or if he is making his way to
Egghead island, that would obviously add A TON
to the ongoing battle. However, even though I
think this is a strong option, it is far from
THE MOST EXCITING option that we have here.
In fact, I’d be WAY MORE EXCITED if a
completely different Blackbeard pirate
was on their way because it is entirely
possible that the former Marine Admiral,
Kuzan, could be the one traveling to Egghead.
And, WOW, if the Ice-fruit user truly is coming
to Egghead then there are SO MANY connections that
we have to make here. Because in case you forgot,
Kuzan was also present during the Buster Call
on the Island of Ohara, and that specific event
has way too many connections to the events on
Egghead. Just start with the escaping civilian
ship for example. Back on Ohara, the current fleet
Admiral Akainu destroyed a similar civilian ship
to prevent secrets from escaping the island.
So wouldn’t it just be so fitting that Kuzan,
who was also present back on Ohara,
do the exact opposite of his marine
counterpart by saving the ship of civilians?
Because remember, at the Ohara incident,
Kuzan let another person escape - that of course
was Nico Robin - because he was unclear about what
was right and he hoped that Robin could prove
that to him with her actions in the future. So
by destroying this marine vessel here, Kuzan
could be showing us that he now has a clearer
sense of his own justice and is determined not to
let the marines kill any more innocent civilians.
But that’s FAR from the only connection Kuzan has
on Egghead because if he is showing up, this would
also be the first time he sees Robin in over
two years. And I for one would be SO EXCITED to
see these two interact again, especially now that
the entire Straw Hat crew could actually put up a
fight against the chilly former admiral. We could
maybe even learn just how much loyalty Kuzan has
to Blackbeard, as many people have even speculated
in the past that Kuzan has his own goals or even
that the former admiral could eventually join
the Straw Hat crew. Though admittedly that would
be a bit of a weird dynamic to have Robin and
the man who used to hunt her down on the crew.
Besides that though, sign me up for a Kuzan and
Kizaru clash because I would just LOVE to see the
current admiral - who is basically a slave to the
world government - fight against the man who chose
to leave the government. Who knows, maybe Kuzan’s
arrival could actually help knock some sense into
Kizaru, and convince the flashy admiral to protect
his friends instead of trying to wipe them out.
On top of ALL THAT, Kuzan could also inform
the Straw Hats about Garp’s capture or death
or whatever really happened to him, which
could actually pose an interesting dilemma
for Luffy. If Garp is captured, does Luffy
abandon his grandpa and continue to Elbaf
like we all assumed and was even confirmed by
Vegapunk? Or if he knows that Garp has been
captured by the Blackbeard pirates, would he
go off and try to rescue his Grandpa? Either
way, we don’t know, but it would be super
interesting to see Luffy have to choose,
and Kuzan could be the perfect one to
bring that information to Egghead Island.
So yeah, clearly I’m all on board the Kuzan to
Egghead train, but that doesn’t mean there aren’t
some other MIND BLOWING possibilities.
It could be Vivi and Big News Morgans,
who were supposed to be making their
way over to Egghead Island. And saving
a bunch of civilians is exactly the kind
of thing Vivi would want to do. However,
there’s even one more option that I actually
think could change the entire world.
And honestly, the pace at which we’re going
here, 2024 is bound to be an absolutely INSANE
Year for us. And if you have someone that
you can share your love for One PIece with,
that makes it just the more exciting if you can
just sit down and watch it together on the couch
crunching down on some delicious snacks, though
it’s still pretty awesome even by yourself. And
if you don’t know how to get THE perfect snack
to watch and read one piece to, don’t worry,
because I got you: This mysterious box is
from today’s sponsor Sakuraco, and it’s a
monthly snack subscription box, that as you can
see is filled to the brim, with just insanely
delicious authentic Japanese snacks from local
makers. In fact there are 20 of them in each box,
and even though i literally live in Japan, the
snacks i buy here are never that good. And these
boxes are loved by my Japanese friends as well, so
you know it’s legit, like imagine Sanji approving
of food. The theme of this box is Valentine’s
Indulgence, celebrating love and sharing food with
whoever you may watch one piece with or also great
yourself, with Peach Dorayaki, Chocolate Danish,
Mini Heart Arare. And I especially love these
strawberry chocolate crunches. There is also
this super cute Kikko plate, that i use
to drink the super calming Cocoa Sencha
Tea in here as well. And so if you also want the
perfect snack japanese snack box to enjoy while
reading the perfect japanese manga, then you can
now use my exclusive code “OHARA” for $5 off for
your first TokyoTreat order. Which actually
brings me right back to this chapter here.
Because remember we still have THIS! Well, what
if this iron Giant wasn’t the only thing that
woke up after hearing Luffy’s heart beat. So yeah,
I’m saying there could be other ancient bits of
technology that heard the Drums of Liberation
and are heading to Egghead to find the source.
Then of course there some other possibilities that
we just have to throw out there. The Revolutionary
Army would certainly make a lot of sense for
why they would want to come. I mean, Kuma came
to Egghead, and they were even discussing where
he could have gone so they probably want to save
him if they can. This would also be THE PERFECT
opportunity to take down one of the Gorosei, which
is the main goal of the Revolutionaries in the
first place, but there is one MAJOR OBSTACLE for
the Revolutionaries to show up here. And that’s
because they are literally on the other side of
the world. Because as we know, the Revolutionaries
now have their base at Kamabakka Kingdom,
which is in the Paradise part of the Grand
Line while Egghead Island is literally on the
other side of the world, near the end of the New
World. The only reason Kuma got here was because
he can fly super fast with his devil fruit, but
unless the rest of the Revolutionaries have some
sort of flying or transportation powers, I just
don’t see how they could arrive here so soon.
However, an EVEN STRONGER
force is much, much closer,
and that is of course the Red Hair Pirates.
Remember that we last last saw them on Elbaf,
which is relatively close to Egghead
island. And you might be asking, well,
why would Shanks come to Egghead? And that’s
actually a great question because there isn’t
really a great answer. Of course, he could
finally want to see Luffy, or maybe he is
after Luffy’s copies of the Poneglyphs. But why
would he come at THIS SPECIFIC TIME? You got me…
However, there is one person on Elbaf with direct
ties to many people at Egghead Island, and that
is the giant Saul, who we recently learned was
still alive AND protecting the knowledge that
was saved from the Library of Ohara. So if he
learned that Vegapunk was in trouble, then I’m
sure he would want to help his former research
buddy. Plus there are Saul’s ties to Robin and
their eventual reunion which just has to happen,
but while we’re throwing out options then if Saul
is coming to Egghead it would make sense that he
would be bringing a whole crew of giants with him,
which would should be more than enough to help
the Straw Hats win the battle on Egghead Island.
Let’s talk about that battle though because wow,
there was A TON to go over from this chapter. The
marine battleships are going crazy bombing the
island. Saturn just ordered all the Pacificstas
to fire their super lasers at Bonney and Kuma,
all while thinking how pathetic they are. Which,
part of me wonders if this is all going to
backfire on Saturn. I mean, we’ve spent this
whole arc going back and forth with whose
side the Pacifista are on. And in the end,
it seems like NO ONE can overrule Saturn,
but now there might actually be one person
who can. That would of course be Kuma,
who was the original Pacifista that all
the others are based off of. So what if he
somehow gains control of them at the last
minute. Maybe because of something Vegapunk
installed or through Kuma's sheer willpower,
and he orders them all to fire on Saturn instead.
THAT. WOULD. BE. INSANE! And I’m 100% here for it.
Besides that though, we basically got an overview
of what all the other straw hats are doing,
which is SUPER HELPFUL because there
is just SO MUCH to keep track of.
First, and most importantly, we finally
got an answer to many mysteries from the
last few chapters involving Luffy. We wanted
to know where he got his food and then where
he disappeared to last chapter! And in a mind
blowing twist, it was actually revealed that
the World Government finally found a way to keep
Luffy from fighting them. They couldn’t capture
him! They couldn’t defeat him with an admiral,
but in this chapter when Luffy was confronted
by the unstoppable temptation of this super high
tech food vending machine, Luffy was helpless.
All jokes aside though, WHAT IS LUFFY DOING?!
I know he’s a hungry guy, and food is basically
energy for him, but leaving a massive fight
while his friends are in serious danger just
so he can have another round of fast food
seems like just a step too far. Seriously,
Kizaru nearly took out Bonney and Kuma AGAIN!
Sanji is running back and forth like a mad
man trying to save those two AND Vegapunk.
But nope, here’s Luffy just chowing down.
Seriously though, I’m trying to not be too
disappointed with this and instead focus
on why Oda would want Luffy to be separated for a
bit. And if you think about it, he does this quite
often during major battles. We've often seen where
Luffy will be missing or trapped or something and
unable to help the rest of the crew. It happened
in Thriller Bark when he was getting his Nightmare
power up and the rest of the crew had to hold
off Moria. It happened in Dressrosa when Luffy
ran out of haki. And even in Wano after being
smacked off the rooftop by Kaido. So it’s really
not that unexpected, but usually, Luffy isn’t
CHOOSING to be separated like he is this time.
But by doing this Oda lets some of the other
Straw Hats shine a bit. Like Sanji putting in
work in this chapter and Franky blasting Saint
Saturn in the previous one. Plus giving Luffy
a break allows us to rebuild some of our fear
of the main enemies since Kizaru and Saturn
are truly threatening the rest of the group
while Luffy is taking his break. And I’m sure
will eventually pay off when Luffy or someone else
needs to step up and protect the crew once again.
However, Sanji’s not the only one putting in work
though and after nearly twenty chapters of not
seeing half the crew, we finally got a recap of
what’s going on for many of them. Nami, Chopper,
and Robin are back in the lab. Brook is helping
the Lilith Vegapunk get the Sunny in position
to leave the island. Zoro is still supposedly
fighting Lucci, which is honestly something I’m
hoping we get to see more of. I mean, if not then
Zoro literally just had a major fight offscreened
for twenty chapters. But I assume we’ll get to
see our green-haired swordsman soon since Jinbe
is heading off to either stop his fight or to find
him in case he is lost somewhere on the island.
So in the end it looks like we are heading for
an escape rather than a full out fight like we
initially hoped for once Saint Saturn
arrived on the island. And truthfully,
I think an escape was always the most
likely scenario. No one even expected
us to be at Egghead once we left Wano anyway, so
it makes sense we wouldn’t truly have a giant,
all out war. But if the crew does end up
just escaping, I will admit to being a bit
disappointed because of all the hype and promises
of a world-shaking event throughout the arc.
I’m still hopeful for the end of this arc though!
And more than excited for whatever is coming next!
And to bring this all back to the end of this
chapter, if this mysterious savior is in fact
a group of giants coming from Elbaf to save the
day, then there could be no better way to kick
off the insanity that is sure to be the Elbaf arc
then with an entire escort of giant viking ships.
And if all this chaos on Egghead plus the roller
coaster of emotions that was Kuma’s backstory,
has got you all mixed up about what we can
expect next, then this video right here is
ABSOLUTELY PERFECT to get you all caught up on
what to expect from the legendary Elbaf Arc.
Shanks for watching, and
I’ll see you in the next one.